the joe rogan experience i'm never on my
phone i can't even tag you on instagram
in the post today to let everybody know
their fight companion
and then there's eddie band
oh no they're
they won't ready me to follow anybody
well that's all i got students to think
i'm a dick
i'm trying to follow you well maybe try
and lay off
some videos i do screenshot video i got
look look boom and i go back look it
says follow now you're following then i
go off the page and i go back follow
back i press it and i go off the page
and then i go like look it keeps going
back to follow back maybe don't call it
a scandamic etc they're gonna rouse
they send me [ __ ] and they go you keep
talking this [ __ ] we're about to pull
your [ __ ] they they warn me somebody
likes you there because at least you're
not andrew kate like they sees his
he was saying things about women that he
was saying that like what what did he
say that specifically got them triggered
because he was basically saying misogyny
look he plays
part of it is like a character and part
of it he's a legit world champion
kickboxer who's a hard man so it's
telling these guys who who doesn't buy
any [ __ ] [ __ ] and that's what's
resonating with young people and he's
also pro-trump the worry is that he is
going to the kids are going to listen to
him because he's he's big on tick tock
my 12 year old and my 14 year old asked
me about andrew tate
i said he's a legit world champion
kickboxer i like him a lot why do you
like him and i was asking them they said
he says a lot of funny stuff on on
twitter and tick tock it's the tick tock
thing because the tick tock algorithm he
did something
where he started something where you
like join his group yeah and then you're
supposed to like post stuff it's
brilliant that's how he gets followers
and but it also gives you a page he blew
up yes it's just hard because he's a
brilliant man yeah my thing is with the
left who wants to cancel him and you
know take him away and like we shouldn't
look up to that okay then who should we
look up to
joe who do you want to fill in for that
but also it's not their job to just say
hey this guy's a danger to young men
what are you talking about like his what
a lot of times he was talking about how
he says become a high value person man
or woman and don't [ __ ] with people
low quality [ __ ] up with the
misogynist yes because if he didn't do
that if he just did the pro mail stuff
yeah
and you know pro accountability and pro
discipline stuff and you know he has
this post he goes
the way i think in the morning the how i
feel has no bearing on what i do he goes
i do everything i'm supposed to do he
goes i get up he goes if i don't feel
good i still work out of course he goes
i still work i still go
i do everything i'm supposed to do
because that's that's how you get ahead
in this life if you just concentrate
entirely on your feelings you're never
going to [ __ ] get anywhere exactly
and that's true and that's a good lesson
for people to learn the problem is the
other [ __ ] the other like there's a
video of him
i don't know what what the context of
the video is he's like that girl no that
was consensual and and by the way what
was it she came out and said they were
both into this role-playing [ __ ] so both
of them she came out and she was like
that's what we're into out of context
though like i'll i'll be honest me and
bert christian were doing a campaign i
didn't see it and it just came out me
and watched i was like jesus christ
what's he doing we didn't have context
i'm like that ain't good yeah he's
[ __ ] but then once you realize she was
she comes out and she's like no hold on
that's what we're into that we both
agreed to that it's like well to each
their own that's what you want to do
right now why is that bad but there's
all these videos that i've laughed my
ass off at dudes ball gagged
like ceos i've not seen them tied behind
their back they're nuts yeah that's
kicked yeah that's okay that's somehow
or another okay exactly but it's because
the guy is the powerful one the guy has
allowed the woman to do that to him yeah
whereas the woman just seems like she's
getting she has no choice yeah yeah but
she said she had a choice apparently
you're saying that's apparently what i'm
hearing yeah she can he you know he did
a lot of good things and you know some
of it was a lot even for but still he
should still have a voice but isn't that
some one of the things you do when
you're trying to push the envelope you
[ __ ] up and you say things you shouldn't
have said right this is the thing about
like trying to be controversial and
trying to get a lot of eyes sometimes
you go over too much yeah and they took
oh [ __ ]
would you ever have tate on your podcast
it's a conversation right he knows what
you know you know who gave him like
literally who brought him on the scene i
knew him from kickbox and was aware of
him for years but really who put him on
scene is tom segura really they don't
give tom enough credit not that he needs
any more credit he's [ __ ] crushing it
but tom really put him on the scene with
like
like our crew like tom's the first one
brought him up yeah i'm on your mom's
house like a year ago i just thought he
was funny i thought some of the stuff he
was saying on his tick tock stuff or
whatever but the best the best christina
pees there and she's like so if i'm a
dumb [ __ ]
because you know how he talks and she's
like okay so i'm a dumb [ __ ] it's so
funny dude
but he did get kind of
cancelled for well he's on rumble now
yeah he's okay they took him over to
rumble which is but but it severely
limits the amount of uh stuff you can
have out there is he banned from youtube
i don't believe uh yeah
so if you listen to carlson
they
his his ability to um his domain name
and all and his ability to monetize it
to
to do transactions with certain
platforms he had a whole school like the
man school he got they took it so i
think like i don't know if it was paypal
but something like that whatever he was
doing transactions
he's no longer allowed to use those
platforms and this should be really this
should be scary for everybody because my
thing is and you know now that i'm
finding a kid or even on my other
million shows i do we talk about covet
or whatever knew someone somebody but
once you're not playing that ballgame
like we're they're suppressing
everything man well you don't get
monetized right they they do monetize
fighting kid although you're not i have
to deal with it all the time king is
singing all the time because we're going
to talk [ __ ] man but we're having fun
but if it's not part of the agenda
they're suppressing if you're talking
steroids if you're talking anything
anything but my whole thing with that is
there has to be another
there has to be somewhere else we can go
where they're not going to do that that
is as big as
no they're not big enough oh you want
like giant numbers any big boys because
that's how that's i sell my tickets on
the road well you see with rumble though
they're getting bigger people over there
now and as they get bigger and bigger
people they made a big play for me when
all that [ __ ] was going down really yeah
they offered me 100 million dollars and
they went for over to rumble but
spotify never did anything they they
stayed with me the entire time yeah i
love spotify for that but the way
they've treated you i'm great i was a
little dicey on spotify and then once
you went over how they've treated you
i'm like
they're great they're great and the you
know daniel eck the ceo at a great
center he goes i'm not going to censor
rappers either i'm not going to censor
some of the things they said how far
should we get if you go back and i mean
if you just go back and listen to early
nwa it's wild [ __ ] or eminem for that
matter
yeah there's so many lyrics of so many
songs not just rap songs that are people
would find
questionable yeah or problematic they'd
have an issue with i would i would go
over there though bring everything if if
they got bigger i think they i think
because they offer tim dillon too right
i think they're doing some with russell
brand or they're trying to what is
rumble who started it i love russell
brand i'm not exactly who started it um
not exactly sure i know dave rubin's a
part of it but i i don't know exactly
he's coming he's coming i don't know
they're starting to do some stuff where
they're getting bigger and bigger names
and if they do that and it becomes
popular enough and they can operate the
way they're doing it right now with no
censorship
it's very it's a very interesting so
quick yeah rumble overnight could be
i would know i
yeah overnight i have eight shows you
know not bad i would move all my [ __ ]
there if it was worth it i think you
move move just
have another have it there too you know
what i mean and the problem is like it's
not
widespread with a lot of people yet but
if someone big went over there like
think about how many people russell
brand has if russell brand i think he's
got like six million youtube followers
now if he goes over there i mean he's
he's already giant starts an influx and
he goes over there and everyone knows
and they just go to rumble it's just a
different clique you have to do it's not
that big people just loyal youtube
they're not loyal rumble rumbles
basically like youtube but they don't
censor people and they don't cancel
that's what i know is that all it is
it's essentially they're they're they're
committed to having a free speech
platform the problem with that is when
people hear that they go oh right wing
oh you're a mega supporter like
immediately think that you're right but
no tulsi gabbard's over there glenn
greenwald is over there dude he's about
awesome he's awesome he's about as
progressive as you get